[موسيقى]
اسعد الله اوقاتكم بكل خير واهلا بكم الى
نشره الخامسه من العربيه التي نستهلها
بابرز العناوين
تعتقد القوى الامنيه هنا انما يجري
تحقيق خاص للعربيه من داخل مخيم الهول
يكشف ان نساء داعش تحملنا دون ازواجهن
وذلك عبر استغلال المراهقين
احباط محاوله اوكرانيه لشن هجوم كبير
بطائرات من دون طيار في القرم وكييف تلوح
بامكانيه الانسحاب من ضخمه
طهران تطرد دبلوماسيين المانيين ردا على
طرد برلين دبلوماسييها ومسلسل تسمم
الطالبات في ايران يتواصل
[تصفيق]
والجيش الاسرائيلي ينفذ حمله اعتقالات في
اريحا والصحه الفلسطينيه تعلن اصابه ثلاثه
فلسطينيين في هذا الاقتحام
اهلا بكم الى نشره الخامسه من العربيه
داخل مخيم الهول في سوريا يتوقف الزمن
مشاهد العنف والتطرف التي رافقت تنظيم
داعش في المناطق التي كانت يوما خاضعه له
تتكرر هنا لكن الاخطر هذه الايام هو ما
رصدته العربيه خلال جولتها الحصريه
جيل جديد للتنظيم داخل المخيم الذي يسجل
ولادات شهريه لنساء داعش اللاتي تحملنا
دون ازواجهم وذلك عبر استغلال المراهقين
والذكور المتعاطفين مع تنظيم داعش لهذه
الغايه
[موسيقى]
يشرح القائمون على اداره مخيم الهول خريطه
اقسامه قبل جوله الاستكشاف الوضع داخله
لكنهم يقولون انما نراه هنا غير كامل
واعداد قاطع المخيم غير دقيقه فهناك حالات
زواج غير موثقه ومواليد جدد يتفاجئون
بوجودهم في خيم الاجنبيات كلما شنوا
عمليات مداهمه وهي خيم يفترض انها تضم
نساء الدواعش واطفالهن فقط فالازواج امه
السجون او قتله تصريح مفاجئ بدا انه يحتاج
شرحا
لنفهم القصه توجهنا الى دلبرين كوباني
القياديه في وحده حمايه المراه في اقليم
الجزيره وهي كانت اشرفت على حمله
الانسانيه والامر التي شمتها القوات
الامنيه ضد خلايا داعش في الهول
قام باجنبي يجب ان يكون قسم الاجنبيات في
المخيم دون رجال اثناء العمليه اكتشفنا
انهم اخفوا المراهقين الذكور في الانفاق
التي حفروها كانوا يفعلون ذلك حتى لا
تتمكن قوات الامن من اكتشافهم انهم
يستخدمون هؤلاء المراهقين لاغراض الانجاب
هناك لاجئون عراقيون وبعض النازحين
السوريين يذهبون خلصت الى قسم الاجانب
للزواج من اجنبيات انهم يستخدمون كل هذه
الطرق لانجاب المزيد من الاطفال
تعتقد القوه الامنيه هنا انما يجري في
المخيم هو استغلال للاطفال والمراهقين
بقرار من التنظيم لذا تقول انها طلبت من
النساء في قسم الاجنبيات تسليم الاطفال
فوق السن الخامسه عشره لاخدهم الى مراكز
منفصله
كما شنت عمليات لمنع تسلل رجال من اقسام
السوريين والعراقيين الى هذا القسم بغرض
الزواج من الاجنبيات حاولنا الحصول على رد
او تعليق نساء الدواعش لكن دون جدوى
غادرنا قسم الاجنبيات واتجهنا لاقسام
السوريين والعراقيين وهي مخصصه لداعشيات
سوريات وعراقيات كما تضم نساء وازواجهن
نزحوا من مناطق السيطره داعش وهؤلاء
يقولون المسؤولون عن الامن هنا انه يصعب
الجزم بعدم ارتباطهم بالتنظيم سابقا او
بخلاياه داخل المخيم حاليا
هذا ناجح سوري يروي بعض ما يجري داخل
المخيم
سمعت انه اكثر من اربعه
يعني اربعه
في واحد معنا مطلوب وخربان منهم قايلين
لزوجته تخلعيه
يعني
يجعل اعداد المواليد شهريا اكبر من
المتوقع
[موسيقى]
عدد الولادات هي كثيره جدا يعني بالشهر
بالشهر اللي فات كان عنا 61 حاله ولاده
باقسام العراقيين فقط
[موسيقى]
جيل جديد باعداد كبيره ينشا في خيم
الدواعش في الهول على الغالب يحاول
التنظيم بهذا ضمان استمراريته وتعقيد مهمه
محاربته صار بن عيشوب العربيه الحسكه
[موسيقى]
افادت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه بانه تم احباط
محاوله من قبل كييف لشن هجوم كبير بطائرات
بدون طيار على اهداف في شبه جزيره القرم
وبحسب الوزاره اسقطت انظمه الدفاع الجوي
سته طائرات بدون طيار كما تم تعطيل اربع
اخرى عن طريق التشويش الالكتروني
ميدانيا قال مستشار رئيس الاوكراني
الكسندر رودنياسكي من قوات بلاده قد تنسحب
من باخموت شرق البلاد
واضاف مستشار رئيس الاوكراني ان الجيش
ينظر في كل الخيارات مشيرا الى انه يسيطر
على المدينه حتى الان ولكن قد ينسحب بشكل
استراتيجي اذا لزم الامر واشار الى ان
روسيا تستخدم افضل قوات مجموعه فاجنر
لتطبيقه
الى موسكو لمزيد من المتابعه تنضم الي
الان مراسله العربيه كاتيا طعامي اهلا
وسهلا بك كيف تعاطت موسكو مع هذا الهجوم
بالطائرات المسيره على شبه جزيره القرم
وهل نتوقع ردا روسيا الليله على هذه
العمليه
حقيقه هذه عمليه الهجوم التي تستمر منذ
يوم امس والتي تحدثت عنها السلطات يوم امس
على خمس مدن روسيه بالاضافه الى
الهجوم الذي
استهدف شبه جزيره القرم اليوم والتي قامت
الدفاع الروسيه بصده هناك نحو ست مسيرات
تم اسقاطها بالاضافه الى تعطيل اربع
بثيرات كما تحدثت الدفاع الروسيه وليس في
الاراضي الروسيه بل بالاضافه للاقاليب
الجديده التي تمت او ضمتها روسيا مؤخرا تم
اسقاط نحو خمسه عشر مسيره في كل من
دونيسكو
وخيرسون ايضا طبعا السلطات الروسيه تتعامل
اولا تحدثت بالنسبه الى كان قد علق على
هذا الهجوم الذي شنته كما تقول موسكو
اوكرانيا كان
مستشار الرئيس
الاوكرنسكي قد نفى طبعا ان اوكرانيا هي من
قامت بشن هذا الهدوء الهجوم وبدورها ان
كان قد تحدث انه لا يصدق ان اوكرانيا لم
تقم بهذا الهجوم وان هذا جاء من الجانب
الاوكراني طبعا
بعد هجوم يوم امس او بعد مسيرات التي
يستهدفت ضواحي موسكو يوم امس كان طبعا قد
تحدث خبراء عسكريون ان العاصمه الروسيه
موسكو هي محاطه بانظمه دفاع جويه قادره عن
اسقاط اي جسم قد يتوجه الى العاصمه
الروسيه موسكو وهي محصنه بشكل جيد عن اي
مسيرات او اي جسم قد يستهدف العاصمه طالب
كانت اخر المعلومات الميدانيه عن الوضع في
باخمت اذا كان لديك
يعني المعلومات الاخيره هي تتحدث عن تقدم
القوات الروسيه والقوات فاجنر على الارض
هناك طبعا هناك طبعا الوضع صعب كما يصفه
بعض الخبراء العسكريون اشتباكات واسعه
وكما يتحدث الخبراء العسكريون ايضا هناك
شبه محاصره
للمدينه من الشمال ومن الجنوب لقطع
الامدادات العسكريه عن القوات الاوكرانيه
ولكن حتى الان لم يتم السيطره على هذه
المدينه ولكن كما وصفه رئيس القوات الخاصه
بان الوضع هناك صعب جدا وقد يحتاج الى
اسابيع للسيطره على المدينه في مدينه طبعا
من موسكو مراسله العربيه شكرا جزيلا لك
كاتي على كل هذه المتابعه
الى شان اخر مسلسل تسمم الطالبات في ايران
مستمر حادثه جديده وقعت صباح اليوم بعد
تعرض طالبات في ثانويتين وابتدائيه للتسمم
في طهران وقد ذكر اولياء امور الطالبات في
المدرسه الثانويه بمنطقه طهران سرا انه تم
اطلاق نوع من الرذاذ في المدرسه تسبب في
هذا التسمم
وفي المدرسه الابتدائيه للبنات بمنطقه
نرمك تم القاء غاز سام ايضا وقد تجمع
اولياء الامور وهتفوا ضد النظام
[موسيقى]
اعلن المتحدث باسم وزاره الخارجيه
الايرانيه ناصر كنعاني عن طردي دبلوماسيين
المانيين ووصفهما بعناصر غير مرغوب فيهم
وقال كنعاني ان تدخلات الحكومه الالمانيه
في الشؤون الداخليه والقضائيه لايران غير
مسؤوله المانيا كانت قد اعلنت في وقت سابق
عن طرد دبلوماسيين ايرانيين بسبب حكم
الاعدام الصادر بحق احد مواطنيها في ايران
الخارجيه الالمانيه كان قد ذكرت انها
تراقب بقلق برامج التسلح الايرانيه
المتقدمه لاسباب عده اقلها ان ايران تصعد
في العديد من المناطق حاليا فضلا عن تخصيب
اليورانيوم في فوردو والقمع الوحشي للشعب
الايراني وانشطه طهران المزعزع للاستقرار
في المنطقه وخارجها من خلال مبيعات
الطائرات المسيره لروسيا
الخارجيه الالمانيه كانت قد اشارت الى ان
قرار طهران بطرد اثنين من دبلوماسيين كان
متوقعا لكنه ليس مبررا
برلين ومنظمات غير حكوميه للدفاع عن حقوق
الانسان نددت بالحكم على المعارض الايراني
الالماني جمشد شارما البالغ من العمر 67
عاما بالاعدام
ايران كانت قد اعلنت في اغسطس من عام 2020
توقيف جمشد شارماهد في من خلال عمليه
معقده دون تحديد مكان او كيفيه تنفيذها
وياتي حكم الاعدام عليه غدا فرض الاتحاد
الاوروبي عقوبات جديده على ايران استهدف
فيها وزيرين ايرانيين و30 كيانم على خلفيه
قمع المظاهرات المندلعه في البلاد منذ
مقتل مرسى امين سبتمبر الماضي
بالعوده الى موضوع او تكرار موضوع تسمم
الطالبات في ايران معي الان من دبي الزميل
مسعود الفك وهو صحفي مختص في الشان
الايراني مسعود اهلا وسهلا بك عندما تتكرر
هذه الحوادث يجب التوقف عندها
مليا
ما يجري هل هو مخطط له وضمن اي اهداف ام
لا هي حوادث عرضيه مسعود
تحيه لكل المشاه الكرام طبعا المشكله هي
في
الحكومه لحد الان رغم انه
عمليات فمهم شملت حوالي 15/10 الى 15
مدينه
وحوالي الف طالبه
دون الطلاب طبعا
تعرض
للتسمم لا تزال الحكومه لم تقدم اي تفسير
وتاويل مقنع حتى البرلمان عندما دعى
وزاره الاستخبارات
والتربيه والتعليم وطلب الاضاحات اعلنت
النواب بان ايضاحات وزاره الاستخبارات غير
مقنعه بهذه الخصوص هذا الوضع اليوم تكرر
ايضا على لسان وزير الداخليه وزير
الداخليه اعلنت بان لا توجد لديه اي
تقارير
حول الماده
سامه او من يقف وراء ذلك طبعا كان معتاد
تحدث ان يكون الاعداء وراء ذلك وقال ربما
ان تكون مغامره شخصيه ولكن لا يمكن
لمغامره شخصيه ان تشمل عشر مدن
والطالب هذه الامور في مجملها دفعت الى
الى فرضيات هناك ثلاث فرضيات الان مطروحه
قد تكون هناك جهه داخل الحكومه تحمل
العقليه الطالبانيه
وترفض
اكمال الدراسه
للبنات
والفرضيه الاخرى هذه سابقه مسعود
نعم
كما هي في طالبان في ايران لم تكن كذلك
حتى حتى في هذا النظام
نعرف الطالبات الان يشكلن اكبر نسبه داخل
الجامعات حتى في ايران لا اعتقد ان هذا
النظريه كثير يعني ليست قويه باعتقادي
النظريه الاخرى تقول بان هناك قد يكون
انتقام للنساء بسبب دورهن في الاحتجاجات
وخاصه الطالبات
ولكن الفرضيه الثالثه قد تكون اكثر
انتشارا الان
وتقول بان السلطات هي التي تقف وراء هذه
المؤامره والهدف من هذه المؤامره هو
الهاء المجتمع وانشغاله بقضيه
وانت تتحدث مع الداخليه الايرانيه تقول
انها لم تتمكن من تحديد الماده التي تسببت
في حالات التسمم طيب سيناريو الثالث الذي
تحدثت عنه يعني اذا كان من مصلحه الحكومه
مثل هكذا حوادث لاشغال الراي العام ولكن
الا تعتقد ان الحكومه والسلطات الايرانيه
هي الاكثر المتضرر الاكبر من ذلك يعني كما
يطلق النار على رجله
نعم هذا هو هذه النظريه نظريه كالشيب ذو
حدين من يريد يلعب هذه الورقه عليه ان
يتوقع ايضا احتجاجات مثلا اليوم شاهدنا
احتجاجات لذوي الطالبات
واولياء الامور باب المدارس ورفعوا شعارات
من الوزن الثقيل الموت للنظام القاتل
للاطفال لذا هذه النظريه الثانيه قد تكون
نتائجها هي بالنسبه لنظام تحريك الشارع
تجديد
الاحتجاجات مره اخرى طيب ساكتفي بهذا
القدر من دبي الزميل الصحفي مسعود الفك
المختص في الشال الايراني شكرا جزيلا لك
مسعود على هذه المشاركه
وبالعوده الى موضوع طرد ايراني دبلوماسيين
المانيين ردا على طرد برلين لدبلوماسيين
ايرانيين معي من برلين الان مراسله
العربيه راغب اهلا وسهلا بك الى اين تتجه
العلاقات الدبلوماسيه بين برلين و طهران
بعد هذا الطرد المتبادل بين الطرفين وهل
مساله استدعاء السفراء من كلا البلدين
مطروحه الان ام لا هذا مستبعد
اهلا بك يعني هذه مطالب المعارضه هنا في
الواقع منذ اليوم الاول لصدور هذا الحكم
كانت مطالب الحزب الرئيسي المعارضه الذي
تنتمي اليه المستشار السابقه بان يكون
هناك طرد للسفيره الايراني وسحب السفير
الالماني من طهران ولكن الحكومه ارتات بان
تاخذ خطوه اوليه طرد ايرانيين من السفاره
هنا وهي كما قالت اليوم يعني توقعت ان
يكون هناك رد ايراني رغم انها اعترضت عليه
وتقول بانه غير عادل الخطوات التاليه الان
تعتمد على ما الذي قد يحصل في ايران ما
اذا كان سيكون هناك استئناف لهذا الحكم
اذا كان سيسمح لهذا المواطن الايراني
الالماني بان يكون بان يحظى بمحاكمه عادله
كما طالبت الخارجيه الالمانيه وايضا
المستشار الالماني الاسبوع الماضي بان
يكون له تمثيل عادل وان يحاكم يعني بشكل
عادل وليس كما هي المحاكمات السوريه التي
تشاهدها ايران حاليا ولكن يعني ردا ايضا
على سؤال حول اين
تتبلوماسيه هي اصلا علاقات متوت جدا في
الوقت الحالي ليس فقط بسبب الاحتجاجات
ويعني المعتقدين الالمان الايرانيين ليس
معتقل واحد في ايران ولكن هناك مواضيع
اخرى كثيره منها التصعيد النووي الذي
شهدناه سمعنا عنه قبل ايام وسمعنا يعني
يوم امس وزيره الخارجيه الالمانيه هنا
تقول مع نظيرها الاسرائيلي بانه لا يمكن
ان نسمح ابدا لايران بان تحظى بسلاح نووي
هذا سيكون خطر على المنطقه كلها لذلك
قطع الايران تصاعد فيما يتعلق بمساله حقوق
الانسان حقوق المراه تحديدا ولكن هي حذره
كما قالت بربوك يوم امس لانها تريد ان
تبقي على هذه كي تمنع ايران من الحصول اذا
كانت مساله يعني استدعاء السفراء او طرد
السفراء غير مطروحه الان هل من الممكن ان
تقدم برلين على خطوه مثل وضع الحرس الثوري
على قائمه الارهاب هذا غير مطروح ابدا
ايضا
يعني الخارجيه الالمانيه هنا تتحجج بانه
يجب ان
داخل الاتحاد الاوروبي والاتحاد الاوروبي
اعطى رايي الاسبوع الماضي قال بانه ليس
هناك اسس قانونيه لوضع الحرس الثوري
الايراني على قائمه الارهاب لانه لم يصدر
بحق هذه المنظمه اي حكم قضائي داخل دول
دوله من دول الاتحاد الاوروبي ولكن في
الواقع يعني هناك انتقادات بانه هذا ليس
قرار يتعلق فقط بالجزء القانوني هناك قرار
سياسي لم يتخذ بعد
يعني تتخذ هذه الخطوه وربما تغضب ايران
اذا ما اردنا القول وتقطع معها كل هذه
العلاقات لانها من دون شك هي متخوفه من ان
تؤدي هذه الخطوه الى قطع العلاقات والحوار
كليا مع ايران وهذا يعني كما ذكرت الان لا
تريده الحكومه الالمانيه بسبب الملف
النووي الايراني ولكن ايضا بسبب علاقه
ايران بروسيا التي تشغل الاوروبيين بشكل
كبير جدا ربما هو يعني واحد من الاولويات
الان في التعاطي مع ايران من برلين مراسله
العربيه راغده بهنام شكرا جزيلا لك راغده
على كل هذه المتابعه
نشاط الخامسه مستمره فيها ايضا
كلهم حراميه
لبنان يبدا رسميا تسعير السلع بالدولار
وسط تحذير من فوضى عارمه تطالوا
المستهلكين
اهلا بكم من جديد الى نشره الخامسه من
العربيه افادت وسائل الاعلام الاسرائيليه
بمقتل فلسطيني واعتقاله اخرين في اقتحام
القوات الاسرائيليه
لمخيم عقبه جبر في اريحا وكانت القوات
الاسرائيليه قد اقتحمت المخيم
ظهر اليوم واعلنت عن عمليه لضبط منفذ
الهجوم في اريحا قبل يومين والذي اسفر عن
مقتل مستوطنين
[موسيقى]
معي من بلده حواره في نابلس مراسل العربيه
خالد القاسم الذي يتابع هذه الاوضاع خالد
اهلا وسهلا بك المشهد اليوم من حواره كيف
بدلك واخر ما
رصدته من مشاهد قبل ان نعرج على موضوع ما
جرى في عقبه جابر في اريحا وان كان
المنطقه بعيدا نسبيا
يعني حوار كمدينه فتحت
للماره وللمركبات ولكن المحل التجاريه كما
تشاهد ما تزال مغلقه بقرار من الجيش
الاسرائيلي الذي يتواجد
بكثافه عند مداخل بلده حواره ويمنع اصحاب
المحل التجاريه من فتح ابوابها حتى ان بعض
المحل التي تضررت بفعل الحرائق
امامنا منع الجيش اصحاب المحل من فتحها
لتنظيفها ولكن بشكل عام احجام حجم الضرر
كبير في ممتلكات ومنشات الفلسطينيين في
بلده حواره وتحديدا معارض المركبات التي
احرقت عن بكره ابيها اضافه الى بعض
المنازل التي
احترقت اجزاء منها بفعل
بفعل هجوم المستوطنين عليها الى بدايه
الاسبوع
الماضي وكما ذكرنا او كما ذكرت في بدايه
الخبر ما تزال قوات الامن والجيش
الاسرائيلي تبحث عن منفذ عمليه اطلاق
النار التي ادت الى مقتل مستوطنين هنا في
هذه المنطقه في بلده حواره بالنسبه الى
اخر التطورات من اريحا تحديدا في مخيم
عقبه جبر هل من معلومات خالد
يعني هي انتهت العمليه العسكريه
في مخيم عقبه جبر بالقرب من مدينه اريحا
حيث داهمت قوات خاصه وقوات كبيره من الجيش
الاسرائيلي المخيم وحصلت مبنى سكنيا كان
هناك تبادل لاطلاق النار اضافه الى اطلاق
نابل الغاز باتجاه
المبنى البيان الجيش الاسرائيلي يقول بانه
اعتقل سته فلسطينيين يقول بان من بينهم
اعضاء الخليه المسؤوله عن اطلاق النار قبل
يومين
على مركبه اسرائيليه ادت الى مقتل
مستوطن
اطقم الهلال الاحمر الفلسطيني تقول بان
احد
الفلسطينيين السته الذين تم
اعتقالهم كان مصابا برصاصه بالصدر الجيش
الاسرائيلي منع الاطقم الطبيه الفلسطينيه
من نقله الى المشافي وتم اعتقاله جريحا
طيب بالعوده الى حواره هل من ضمانات ستعطى
للفلسطينيين في حال العوده خالد املا كل
حديث عن ضمانات لا يجري الحديث عنه ابدا
يعني ممن هي الضمانات يعني اليوم رئيس
الوزراء الفلسطيني محمد شتيه كانوا هنا
وقال
لن نعود لنطلب الحمايه الدوليه يجب ان
نحمي انفسنا يجب ان نعود الى الحياه وحدنا
الامور هنا قابله للاشتعال لاي تصرف فردي
سواء من قبل مستوطن يطلق النار او فلسطيني
يقوم باطلاق النار
لا ضمانات لان لا سيطر على هذه الاحداث
لاي جهه كانت سواء اسرائيل او السلطه
الفلسطينيه هذه هي عمليات فرديه يقوم بها
الفلسطينيون
والجيش الاسرائيلي بحسب المحللين
الاسرائيليين بعد مشاهدات ما حدث يوم
الاحد الماضي من هجوم عشرات المستوطنين
على منازل الفلسطينيين قال المحللون بان
الجيش الاسرائيلي على ما يبدو فقد السيطره
على شوارع الضفه الغربيه واطلق العنان
للمستوطنين لاخذ القانون بيدهم من بلده
حواره في نابلس مراسل العربيه خالد القاسم
شكرا جزيلا لك خالد على كل هذه المتابعه
مع زياده الغضب الشعبي في اسرائيل حياه
لخطت الحكومه لتغيير النظام القضائي خرج
مئات المتظاهرين للاحتجاج ما ادى الى
استخدام الشرطه الاسرائيليه لقنابل صوتيه
لتفريق المتظاهرين وقد علق رئيس الوزراء
بنيامين نتنياهو على المظاهرات مشددا على
رفضه للعنف ضد عناصر الشرطه واغلاق الطرق
وخرق القوانين
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
لمزيد من المتابعه حول هذا الموضوع معي من
القدس الان مراسله العربيه لانا كالغاصي
لان اهلا وسهلا بك جديد مشهد التازم
والتوتر في الداخل الاسرائيلي والى اين
تتجه الامور
نعم يعني هذه فعليه المظاهرات التي تستمر
للاسبوع التاسع على التوالي اما اليوم هو
يعني تحت عنوان يومها شيبوش اي يوم
الاضطراب هناك عشرات او عشرات الالاف نشير
الى عشرات الالاف من الاسرائيليين خرجوا
منذ صباح اليوم للتظاهر في عده مناطق في
اسرائيل تل ابيب عدد من المدن قاموا
بتسكير عدد كبير من الشوارع الرئيسيه التي
بدات هذه المظاهرات منذ صباح اليوم تحديدا
الساعه الثامنه صباحا يعني في توقيت القدس
وتستمر حتى الساعه الثامنه يعني ليلا اما
الان هناك يعني كما ترون عشرات
الاسرائيليين يتوجهون لتظاهر امام الكنيست
هناك مظاهره سوف تبدا يعني بعد قليل امام
الكنيست الشرطه الاسرائيليه بدات ايضا
بتجهيز هناك عدد من او عشرات القوات
الاسرائيليه ايضا شاهدنا قبل قليل مرور
الخيل التابع للشرطه الاسرائيليه دخل الى
من هذه الفتحه التي ترونها يعني ويعني
هناك اعدادات كبيره شاهدنا في ظهر اليوم
هناك تواجد لعشرات يعني سجلت الاحصائيات
هناك 43 الف متظاهر تواجدوا فقط في تل
ابيب للتظاهر ضده فعليا هذه الاصلاحات
القضائيه يعني نتحدث عن غضب كبير في
الشارع الاسرائيلي خاصه ان اليوم تحديدا
يعني هناك استخدام للعنف حسب ما وصفه
المتظاهرين الاسرائيليين استخدم القوات
الاسرائيليه استخدمت الخيل استخدمت
القنابل الصوت ورمتها على المتظاهرين
لتفريق هذه المتظاهره ايضا يستخدموا
المياه العادمه وفعليا شاهدنا في الاسابيع
الماضيه عادات كبيره وكبيره جدا يعني
تجاوز المئه الف متظاهر ولكن لم نرى
استخدام العنف ضد المتظاهرين ولكن يعني من
اوامر من بنك فير صباح اليوم كان هناك
يعني اوامر من بنجزير بان يتم فعليا منع
تسكير الشوارع من قبل المتظاهرين وهناك
يعني ما ما يقارب 11
مصاب دعنا نشير اسرائيلي تواجدوا في في
المظاهره اليوم من القدس مراسله العربيه
لانك الغاصي شكرا جزيلا لك لنا على كل هذه
المتابعه
مع انطلاق عمليه الدوله في الاسواق
اللبنانيه عبر المواطنون عن رغبتهم
بالتسعير وفقا لعملتهم الوطنيه
وبينما اكلت وزاره الاقتصاد ان من شان هذه
الخطوه لازم جشع بعض التجار وتقليص الفرق
بالاسعار اشتكى المواطنون من اختلاف سعر
الصرف بين متجر واخر
صباح الاربعاء لم تفتح ابواب المتاجر في
موعدها ففي الداخل لم ينتهي الموظفون بعد
من تحويل اسعار السلع من العمله اللبنانيه
الى الدولار
عادت الارقام الصغيره حجما الى الرفوف
لكنها كبيره على جيب من يقبض راتبه
بالليره
قرروا دولتي اسعار السوبر ماركت الذي
اتخذته وزاره الاقتصاد يتحكم به التجار
فهذا المنتج مثلا سعره بالليره لان التاجر
رفض بيعه بالدولار وبعض المنتجات حتى وان
كانت لبنانيه الصناعه الا انها امريكيه
القيمه المفروض نحن نقبض لبناني لازم
يبيعوا بلبنان شو الدولار ما بنقبل دولار
وكل شيء غالي
مين راح
ما بدنا غير لبناني بين سوبر ماركت واخر
اختلف المشهد فهنا غابت الاسعار تماما عن
الرفوف بانتظار ان تكتمل استعدادات المتجر
اما المواطن غير المجبر على الدفع
بالدولار لا يعلم حجم الفاتوره الذي
ينتظره خاصه انه يدفع وفقا لسعر صرف اختلف
بين متجر واخر الدولار عنا متقلب منه ثابت
مشان هيك رح تلاقي فرق بسعر من بسوبر
ماركت لسوبر ماركت او اذا حضرتك فايته على
السوبر ماركت راح تلاقي فرق انتو وفرق
انتو عم تدفعي اولا حديث الوزير شهر لليوم
عن اعلان الدوله لا تسبب بانفلات الاسعار
نحو الغلاء بشكل جنوني جدا اليوم لا يوجد
من يراقب الاسعار سواء كان بالليره
اللبنانيه ام بالدولار الامريكي قرار
الوزير ان يصدر من جهه رسميه اعلان الدوله
راه هذا الامر مخالف لقانون النقد
والتسليف ولقانون حمايه المستهلك بغياب
الرقابه لفرق بين اللبناني واعجمي فالتجار
سيجدون دائما المنفذه لتحقيق ارباحهم على
حساب جيب المواطن فوضى وغموض وضيعه هكذا
بدا اليوم الاول من التسعير بالدولار وسط
غياب واضح لمراقبيه وزاره الاقتصاد التي
تقول ان خطوتها اتت لحمايه المواطنين غنوه
يتيم العربيه
اذهب الى بيروت لاله مزيد من المتابعين
انضم اليه من هناك الخبير الاقتصادي
والماليه الدكتور نيكولا شيخاني دكتور
نيكولا فقط لنشرح للمشاهدين العرب
ما سر هذا الانهيار المخيف بسعر صرف
العمله في لبنان وهل الامور منفلته من اي
عقال يعني دون اي ضوابط ولماذا لا يتدخل
المصرف المركزي كما كان يتدخل في السابق
مرحبا خالد وتحيه انا طالب مش خالد
ولمشاهدين العربيه بلبنان وبكل الشرق
الاوسط بدنا نعرف انه
مشكله الدولار بلبنان هي لانه بنك المركزي
ما عنده خطه نقديه يعني
بالانجليزي اليوم لبنان صاروا 15 سنه بلا
خطه نقديه لمصرف لبنان
سنه
مع انه ما في نمو اقتصادي مع انه ميزان
مدفوعات سلبي والميزانيه الدوله سلبه يعني
عندك توين ديفيست ما فيها الا ما يحرق
احتياطه بالعمله اليوم مصرف لبنان حرق
احتياطه بالعمله وبما انه ما عنده
خطه نقديه طلع تعامين تكتيكيه سمعوا فيهم
اللبنانيه 151 54 58 هن تعضهميه شو
معناتها يعني طبع ليره كان في عنا باول
الازمه من ثلاث سنين
خمسه
وسبعين تريليار ليره التضخم بالكتله
النقديه وشح الدوله واحتياط مصرف لبنان
بالعمله الصعبه
الليره اللبنانيه يعني مثل ما بقولوا
اليوم اللي عم بيصير على الارض انه بما
انه ما في خطه نقديه بعد لمصرف لبنان ومش
عم نعرف ليش ما فيها الخطه النقديه مش
صعبه يعني هي مهمته يركب خطه نقديه اللي
عم بيصير على الارض انه الارض عم يجرب
يتاقلم على تدهور اللي يراو على الدولار
القذره يعني
شو عم بيصير اول فقره
كانت هي دوله المطاعم اليوم بتروح على
لبنان اللي بتزعل على المطاعم سعر البيتزا
بالدولار
غلت الاسعار بالمطاعم اليوم البيتزا اغلى
يعني اللي معه دولار هلا بعيش اللي ما معه
دولار بيموت من الجوع يعني هل هذه على هذا
النحو واي انعكاسات سواء ماليه اقتصاديه
وحتى اجتماعيه لهذا الانهيار الى اين
ستذهب الامور
هلا رح روح ابعد معك المعه دولار معقول
يعيش لانه صار في غلا على الدولار
مش بس غالي على الليره يعني الاسعار
بالدولار غليت لانه ما في رقابه وما في
مقارنه اسعار اليوم لما بدك تدوري الاسعار
بدك تنزل رقابه بدك تنزل مقارنات للاسعار
واليوم مش موجوده هذه دوله الاسعار حتى
يتاقلم التاجر والسوبر ماركت والبلايس من
كوست تبعه
ما ما ينصاب فيه بس من زيت الوقت انضرب
المجتمع يعني اليوم بيقبض بالليره او بعد
في كتير العالم بتقبض بالليره ما في يلحق
بقى اليوم راح يصير في ازمه مش بس
اقتصاديه بس ازمه اجتماعيه ويخاف منه هي
الازمه الامنيه لانه في ازمه اجتماعيه
بيتدهور الامن وبما انه اليوم
بيحملوا الامن بلبنان من الجيش وامن عام
وغيره اليوم اليوم يعني بيقبضوا عشرين
دولار بالشهر كارثه الكوارث من عدم
المساعدات اكيد لو كل يوم خطر امني خطر
انهيار اجتماعي وخطر مش خطر صار في انهيار
اقتصادي وهيدا لانه ما في عندك سياسه
نقديه ولا سياسه ماليه على على مستوى
الدوله راس الهرم مضروب وعم بيتراكم على
على الشعب اللبناني بتدهور سعر الصرف
بتدهور الاقتصاد والعمله بتدهور الاجتماعي
وبتدهور ان شاء الله لا الامني طيب دكتور
انت وصفت ما يجري ولكن لو سالتك شو الحل
من اين يجب ان يبدا الحل يعني ما في مشكله
الا ما لها حل ام لا يعني ثلج لا تعالج في
لبنان كما يقول المثل
ثلج بس عالج لانه هلا شعب متل ما هو بموت
لا في حلول اكيد في حلول الحل هو اول شيء
انه يصير فيه استقرار سياسي اليوم بلبنان
ما في راي الجمهوريه ما في رئيس وزاره
البرلمون عم يتخبط ما عم يقدر يصوت دونك
الماكينه السياسيه وقفت ولما المكنه
السياسيه بتوقف ما بقعد في قرارات تنفيذيه
حتى نقدر نحقق قرارات لما اصلاحات اليوم
الدوله اللبنانيه مده اتفاق اولي مع صندوق
اللعب بس مش عم تقدر تحقق الاصلاحات
الطلبه انا رايي كمان ما بدي تحققهم لانه
في كثير تضاربات سياسيه بهالاصلاحات
طالما اليوم ما في رئيس جمهوريه ما في
رئيس وزاره
ومعنا
يعني الويل حتى نعمل هالاصلاحات لا في
مشكل في مشكل اليوم الاقتصاد رح ليه رح
دلت الدهور طالما مصرف لبنان ما عنده خطه
نقديه مع خط الدوله ماليه لو في مشكله
باولها الدوله اللبنانيه لازم ترجع تركب
تاني اشي مصرف لبنان لازم يرجع يحط يعمل
الخطط النقديه لازم حتى يحملوا الاقتصاد
للاسف يوم اول شيء جمهوريه من بيروت نعم
من بيروت الخبير الاقتصادي والماليه
الدكتور نيكولا شيخاني شكرا جزيلا لك على
هذه المشاركه
الخامسه مستمره فيها ايضا
الدنمارك تلغي عطله رسميه لرفع ميزانيه
التمويل الدفاعي وسط رفض شعبي لهذه الخطبه
اهلا بكم من جديد ذكرت بعثه الامم المتحده
للمساعده في افغانستان ان نحو 700 الف شخص
فقدوا وظائفهم على مدار الاشهر الماضيه
وسط ظروف المعيشيه قاسيه يعيشها الافغان
المزيد في التقرير التالي
كارثه انسانيه وظروف قاسيه غذاها استيلاء
حركه طالبان على السلطه في افغانستان
ادخلت البلاد المثقله من الحروب في دوامه
مشاكل اجتماعيه عده على راسها الفقر
والبطاله اجمالي الدخل في البلاد تراجع
بواقع 35% ونحو 700 الف شخص فقدوا وظائفهم
على مدار الاشهر الثمانيه عشر الماضيه هذا
التراجع لم يتراكم من عدم فمن اهم العوامل
التي ساهمت في ارتفاع معدلات البطاله في
افغانستان انقطاع الدعم الخارجي واغلاق
مكاتب المساعدات والمشاريع الدوليه اضافه
لفصل الكثير من الموظفين السابقين في
الجهات الحكوميه وتعيين عناصر طالبان بدلا
منهم اما النساء فكان لهن النصيب الاكبر
من المنع من العمل في القطاع العام والخاص
فيما اقتصاديا هناك نزوح لرؤوس الاموال
والمستثمرين من افغانستان وافلاس شركات
القطاع بسبب القيود الاقتصاديه على حكومه
طالبان ومنع المعاملات الماليه البنكيه
الدوليه كما ان قرابه 65% من المواطنين
يحتاجون الى مساعدات انسانيه وسط غلاء
معيشي قياسي طال ابسط واهم ركائز المعيشه
كالسلع الغذائيه فيما يواجه الملايين من
الافغان خطر مجاعه كارثيه عوامل اقتصاديه
صعبه وفقر قهر العائلات الافغانيه تسبب في
قيام بعضهم ببيع اطفالهم لاجل تامين لقمه
العيش حسب تقارير لمنظمات انسانيه ولا
يزال الافغان يدفعون الثمن الاكبر منذ
سيطره طالبان على الحكم والتي ادت لعزله
دوليه بعد قطع المجتمع الدولي العلاقات
المباشره مع افغانستان
كشفت وزاره الدفاع الامريكيه ان كبار
مسؤوليه دفاع في الولايات المتحده والصين
لم يتحدثوا منذ نوفمبر الماضي وذلك على
هامش قمه رابطه دول جنوب شرق اسيا اسيا في
كمبوديا في مؤشر على التوترات المتصاعده
بين البلدين وبحسب بلومبر يسلط انقطاع
الاتصالات بين البلدين لاكثر من ثلاثه
اشهر يسلط الضوء على مدى تاثر العلاقات
بين البلدين خصوصا بعد قضيه المنطاد
الصيني الذي اسقطته واشنطن بعد وصفه
بمنطاد التجسس وهو ما نفته الصين بالاضافه
الى تصاعد الخلافات ايضا بشانه تايوان
كما ان الصين رفضت جهودا امريكيه لترتيب
مكالمه هاتفيه بين وزيري الدفاع الامريكي
ونظيره الصيني لتخفيف التوترات بعد حادث
المنطاد في اوائل فبراير الماضي
عن ارتفاع حصيله ضحايا حارث اصطدام
القطارين في اليونان الى سته وثلاثين
قتيلا
[موسيقى]
صوت البرلمان الدنماركيه على الغاء عطله
عامه في الربيع لتعزيز الاقتصاد بهدف رفع
ميزانيه التمويل الدفاعي
المشرعون صوتوا باغلبيه خمسه وتسعين صوتا
مقابل 68 لالغاء يوم العطله العامه وهو
يوم عطله ديني يحتفل به منذ القرن السابع
عشر
وبحسب الحكومه الدنماركيه سيوفر الالغاء
427 مليون دولار لاستخدامها في ميزانيه
وزاره الدفاع كاحدى نتائج الحرب الروسيه
الاوكرانيه
وقد تجمع الاف المحتاجين من السياسيين
والنقابات العماليه والشخصيات الدينيه
خارج البرلمان للاحتجاج على هذه الخطه
مع التطور السريع للذكاء الاصطناعي يعمل
علماء من جامعه
الامريكيه على تطوير حواسيب حيويه ذكيه
تحاكي وظائف ملايين من خلايا الدماغ
البشريه
المحاكاه تركز على مجموعه من اليات التعلم
والذاكره في الكائنات العضويه ودمجها
بابتكارات تقنيه لتطوير الذكاء العضوي
بالاعتماد على رقائق السيليكون مستهلكه
طاقه اقل وفق صحيفه البريطانيه
هذه التكنولوجيا بحسب العلماء تهدف لدراسه
الوظائف المعرفيه في الدماغ وتوسيع نطاقها
لتحقيق قدرات حسابيه تستخدم في انشاء
نماذج للذكاء لدراسه اساس الوظائف
الادراكيه للانسان ولا تستخدم هذه
التكنولوجيا فقط في مجالات الذكاء
الاصطناعي بل ايضا تساهم في البحث عن
المواد السامه المسببه للامراض العصبيه
مثل مرض الزهايمر وتحديد علاجاتها
نشره الخامسه المفصله من العربيه انتهت
اطيب التحيات والسلام عليكم ورحمه الله
وبركاته
[موسيقى]